watching them eat themselves alive is
just spectacular it's glorious we got
the we got the warning yeah we got
something from The View here's something
one of my issues has always been one of
many I don't understand how a Latina
woman right who even left them from
Nicaragua could be part of a of a party
what is wrong with this woman when it
came to this country when I came to this
country the Republican party was the
party that stood up against communism
still is and that is something that is
ingrained in me in the same way that
being a Catholic is ingrained in you all
of this has nothing to do with the
question
to turn to a Latino woman and say you
are not in command of your mind you are
you must vote the way that I want you to
vote if you think that all black people
must vote a certain way or all gay
people must vote a certain way and they
must think the way you think they must
think you are the racist you are the
bigot that is the summation of what the
left has